tomorrow's world ready to be explored at
the international motor show in
frankfurt cars that can see and hear
fitted with sensors radars and cameras
intelligent vehicles thanks to digital
technology
advanced driver assistance systems or a
das help drivers navigate through
traffic
no more accident because of blind spots
if a car V is of course the wheel
vibrates and response intelligent
vehicle technology is already a reality
but researchers are fine-tuning it all
the time fatigue detection for example
the help sends all for the mudak tight
circle is telling Kringle sends all the
main sensor for fatigue detection is the
steering angle sensor the driver is
characterized on the basis of his or her
steering characteristics the way they
steer in other words there are various
ways that people drive so if you're on
the highway the system can detect when
you start to get tired the system is
linked to the navigation and knows that
a service station is coming up ahead and
can alert the driver shorter than
offensive Australian to farthen Marco
Schneider from continental a major
automotive supplier researches emergency
brake assistance at the international
motor show visitors can see what happens
when a car traveling at 50 km/h has to
make an emergency stop
lasers and cameras allow for early
detection of danger standish for the
TSA's team imagine if the system could
work at such an early stage that the
driver would say well I don't need the
system because there would have been a
chance to steer clear of the obstacle or
break you need to decide exactly how to
calibrate a system so that it only
breaks from the driver has no chance of
avoiding an accident keine
Schwarzenegger updated even felt super
might technological advances reserved
for higher-end vehicles will eventually
trickle down to the Affordable brands
experts say that the advanced driver
assistance systems help reduce the
number of accidents but they also warn
against overwhelming drivers with new
technologies
baba asistencia stephen driver
assistance systems are intended to help
drivers particularly in critical
situations it's very important that they
don't distract them for example if the
light is too bright or blinks in a
hectic manner drivers should not be
reacting to the system but instead
controlling their vehicles delay thus
far types of the hessian smartphones can
be a dangerous distraction to avoid that
cars of the future will be directly
plugged into the internet and drivers
will be able to choose from a wide range
of apps including anything from
entertainment to safety information
British up-market car manufacturers
Bentley offer their exclusive customers
a car that acts as a mobile office
complete with internet connection and a
device that allows you for example to
operate the radio from the back seat
in this luxury segment of the market
autonomous motoren usually means that a
shipper is behind the wheel
in the meantime most car manufacturers
are working on the idea of a car that
can drive itself this involves a vehicle
that is networked with its surroundings
for our sensors and radars and can
accurately assess an immense amount of
data at the moment this is still the job
of human beings am in Jessica people are
definitely able to master complex
situations that they encounter for the
first time an intelligent machine is
still unable to do that at the moment
smart cars and technology may be helpful
in the future but they can't replace the
pure joy of driving